today we're going to be speaking with Dr
Eli Merritt who's a political historian
at Vanderbilt University and also editor
of the recently released collection of
essays the curse of dimagogues Lessons
Learned From the presidency of Donald J
Trump it's really great to have you on I
appreciate your time
thanks good to be here David so I I
think this one place to start would be
one of the big discussions that's now
happening in the aftermath of the Trump
presidency and you know we're still
waiting to know whether there will be
criminal charges or not and that may be
part of this conversation
did we learn that the checks and
balances and safeguards put in place by
the founders were not strong enough if
we had a president interested and
willing to do the things Trump did or or
is that too bold a statement to make
right now
well I think we learned that lesson and
something else uh the the checks and
balances that were put in place by the
founders uh back over 200 years ago as
you know with the Electoral College and
the powers of impeachment and conviction
and disbarment from future office yes
for very long the electoral college has
not worked and so the real truth is soon
after uh the the Constitutional
Convention 1787 ratification 1788
political parties became the dominant
instruments of our politics and also
they became the dominant instrument of
checks and balances against demagogues
and authoritarians making it to the
presidency so I I many things I believe
failed in the Years 2015 until
continuing today but the most
significant failure of checks and
balance is the most significant failure
of Gatekeepers against demagogues who
become authoritarians is clearly the
political parties our political parties
are woefully weak today and we can talk
more about sort of the origins of that
but they became relatively emasculated
starting in the early 1970s when all
checks and balances at the nominating
conventions were removed let's talk a
little bit more about that you know I I
have not found anyone who disagrees with
me that Donald Trump could not have won
a Democratic primary now the reasons why
people might disagree with my reason is
a little bit crude which is even though
I'm neither a republican nor a Democrat
I don't believe Democrats would have
fallen for what Trump was offering
whereas the Republican electorate by
definition did fall for it in that they
made him the nominee in 2016. uh is that
a fair is that one of the differences
right now between the parties in terms
of the constituents and then are the
differences between the constituents
greater than the differences between the
party structures
I would say it seems very clear right
now at this point in our history that
the Democratic party is the party of the
Constitutional rule of law it is the
party of ethical leadership no party's
perfect and no and no and and the
entirety of the political uh figures
politicians in any party are not ethical
um but I think it's a hard question to
ask Democrats would never elect Trump
but I I think the most important thing
to clarify here
is that we have descended somewhat into
what I like to refer to as a demagogic
culture
and I I would not ever remove the
possibility that as the culture and the
politics become more and more Fierce and
some a liberal-leaning demagogue might
come along who has similar Tendencies
and angers and frustrations and a
personality as Fierce as Trump's
and if we get into this black and white
thinking if we think the other side is
evil I do believe Democrats are also
susceptible to uh demagogues that's why
what we do in one party is something we
should do in other parties and again I
think the most important area of
intervention the most flexible point of
intervention is the uh presidential
nominating system a lot of people don't
know that very little law governs
certainly not the Constitution governs
political parties and the nominating
conventions right so it's just a matter
of the party's deciding to make changes
and they could do some inter-party
compacts to use to to guarantee that
each of them will veto the emergence of
individuals who clearly do not support
the Constitution will not solemnly swear
to uphold free and fair elections in the
peaceful transfer of power and other
things when we talk about
today I think the Democratic party feels
quite safe I really do I agree with you
there that it would feel like hubris to
predict over the next 10 or 15 or 20
years if we don't clean some things up
that they could become susceptible to
demagogues oh I agree I all of my
assessments are as of today and you know
when when we hear people say when Trump
would say at the State of the Union the
U.S will never be a socialist country
it's sort of like never is a long time
you know maybe not I don't think next
year there's not too many socialists
right now in positions of power but I
think never that we want to be careful
with never if we go back to 2016 a
little bit there's a lot of blame that
is often placed for how Trump how no
everybody failed to stop Trump and
sometimes it's you know James Comey
doing that extra press conference to
talk about Hillary's emails that was
totally unnecessary that was the
Difference Maker because it was so close
or the media giving free publicity to
Trump is what allowed him to keep
accreting two three four percent every
time another primary candidate dropped
out that was the reason or
Democrats selecting a poor candidate in
Hillary Clinton is what's to blame now
when it's so close it's very hard to say
one thing is to blame because any one of
those things could make a difference but
given that
how do we assess the lack of ability to
have stopped Trump in 2016.
I I think that responsibility goes
around everywhere to our basic education
system to the structure of our news
media as you're saying and uh you know
events like James comey's relief release
of the emails or his judgment about that
are very significant but I would again
posit that
the only Surefire direction to go is for
political parties to block the emergence
of demagogues and authoritarians
entirely from entering the general
election if I'm not mistaken all of your
questions related to the general
election and so there are certainly
there are reforms that can help to
prevent a demagogue authoritarium within
the uh general election from succeeding
but they become for their base you know
religious figures and addictive figures
so the most important thing that can be
done
if if there were two things I would
recommend it would be first and foremost
that the political parties do their job
and return to the party having the power
and the platform having the power and
the candidate having to adjust to the
platform which I think should begin in
both parties to have statements that
surround the Constitution and the oath
of office for example the other thing
where we woefully failed
is is in the process of impeachment
conviction and disbarment from future
office
the fact that after January 6 after four
to five years of witnessing Trump's uh
bigoted speech and damage to our to our
nation that 43 Senators voted not to
convict him either shows they do not
understand democracy they do not
understand demagogues they do not
understand that democracies can fail or
that they succumbed to the cowardice
pathway of hyper partisanship so I think
both play the roles of those are the two
most important places for intervention
we could make an effort to at least
educate our politicians to understand
these phenomena better you know the
interesting thing about that is what you
describe is what many Bernie Sanders
supporters
say happened in the 2020 primary and
they don't like it and what I mean by
that is there is a story that's told and
there's degrees of truth to all of these
things of course that despite the people
wanting Bernie
the party coordinated
uh I'm now searching into my memory but
it was I believe Pete bootage and a
couple other people getting out at the
perfect time to get Biden South Carolina
with which he built momentum to
eventually become the nominee we all
know the story and a lot of people are
angry because they say now the people
should have the power even if Bernie
whether Bernie was destined to win or
lose in a general election it should be
the people not the party that gets to
decide you're saying something quite
different which is actually the party
needs to be the Safeguard
I'm saying something completely
different I do I believe powerfully in
representative government
and representative government has always
focused representative government with
layers of democracy and layers of checks
and balance this is always survived and
functioned better than pure direct
democracies so yes what I would actually
like to see happen in the reform I I
think would solve or get close to
solving the problem of demagogues
getting into the White House would be to
let the parties pick the presidential
nominees and let the people pick the
president that is in fact the way it was
done for approximately 190 years in our
country and we switched that in the
early 1970s and I think we're living the
consequences of making that switch so I
would have the people be very involved
in voting the people would vote for the
delegates
and hopefully by ranked Choice voting
that may be something you've covered on
your program indeed indeed
and then the delegates would go the
stepwise fashion to the way it used to
be done is County Convention State
conventions and the national conventions
I think today they would just go
straight to the National Convention and
there they do their work just like the
elect uh delegates to the House of
Representatives in this country we elect
them to go up there and do work which is
to study the situation and make
determinations so the first thing these
elected delegates would do is establish
the party platform and then they would
determine which of the candidates who
are involved actually will fulfill the
mission of the party platform and not
take over the party the way Trump has
done most most countries in the world
and variations do something like I've
just described very few countries have
direct primaries and I I do believe they
will continue to be uh arrows in our
sides and possibly fatal to our
democracy meaning we will become a sham
democracy not meaning we're going to
engage in Ultimate Civil War but it's a
sad thing for me to think will be a sham
democracy we're only a democracy and
name and otherwise corrupt officials are
are engineering everything behind the
scenes to look forward a little bit I'm
curious about your assessment of what is
currently happening within the
Republican Party in the sense that we
have these very unusual circumstances in
which this demagogue Trump made a very
early announcement that he's running in
2024 he has barely left his home since
making the announcement it's unclear
really what the case is that he's going
to make for his next nomination a guy
who hasn't announced anything Ron
DeSantis is actually leading Trump in
some polling the speakership Fiasco from
the last week has exposed it's no longer
just Pro and anti-trump even within the
Trump side you've seen this division
Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren bobert
on opposing sides of that division is
something fundamentally changing here
um do you I want to ask you to say more
about that change what something
changing in the Republican party for the
better or worse is that what you're
alluding to well better or worse is more
of a value judgment but is the dynamic
of it's the people for and against Trump
and it's that simple is that Dynamic
changing where you're actually getting
even more fracturing where the Maga side
is now dividing
well I I think what what what Trump has
done is he has opened the mainstream of
the Republican party and the nation to
some extent to what Nelson Rockefeller
called back in the 1960s this is his
location The Lunatic Fringe so I think
it's hard to predict though 20
um Republicans who or so who were
opposing Kevin McCarthy yeah I just
think evidence a lot of qualities in
general
that are very destructive to
representative government it is
grandstanding it is not thinking of the
best interest of the nation it's a
little bit of this Lunatic Fringe coming
in
so where things go I am not certain I I
do know that we continue to have within
the Republican Party the the forces of
Mitt Romney who have been somewhat
profoundly weakened I should say yeah so
I don't know where the future of it is
my real hope would be
that at some point that there will be a
conservative party that splits off from
this Republican party and that the
American people decide that this way of
living through uh demagoguery and lies
and and fear-mongering and hate
mongering is not something they wanted
but we did that experiment now we want
to move on from it that's my hope so but
I do think Ron DeSantis uh clearly their
their criticisms of him he he's not a
demagogue if you just look at him speak
you'll determine the man is does not
have the rhetorical talents and
destructive abilities of of trump some
people worry he could become somewhat
authoritarian
but I've looked carefully at what he's
done in Florida and there's some
questions there yeah to my evaluation
this answers appears for the
Constitution to be a much safer bet than
Donald Trump and Donald Trump I think is
something's happening for him I think
he's becoming somewhat deflated uh by
what's happening and so hopefully he
will he he could implode and and and
become more dangerous to our democracy
as we have seen with his comments about
the Constitution yeah but it's all quite
unpredictable as I'm sure you agree when
we look in history what sort of events
have catalyzed realignments in parties
were parties significantly shift
uh I think it what what one discovers
I'm thinking of the beginning of the
Republican Party in the 1850s when you
asked that there is a sense that there
is a national crisis that the uh that
someone needs to address and the Whig
party for example at that time yeah was
determined not to be willing to go in
the direction that the Republican Party
wanted at that time and it was clearly
not an anti-slavery platform but it was
an anti-expansion of slavery platform so
a critical mass had been met there
where they felt this sickness has gone
on in our nation long enough
and we cannot get Traction in these
other parties and critically back then
there was more flexibility in the system
certainly there was not this entrenched
money in politics and the political
industrial complex that makes it so hard
to form third parties now that's a bit
of a challenge and it's very worrisome
that third parties can be wonderful
things and again you know the Republican
party was a third party yeah that
rapidly grew and did well so I think
it's crisis and so it could be that the
current crisis of demagoguery and
authoritarianism and Corruption that
we're beginning to witness now that
could in the hands of Eliz Cheney for
example
become a catalyst for starting a third
party and I think it should be done even
if predictions are it can't succeed we
need to see people do the right thing
and make efforts in spite of the fact
that there's concern that we are a
hopeless two-party system yeah I could
not could not agree with you more on
that um the collection of essays
recently released is the curse of
dimagogues Lessons Learned From the
presidency of Donald J Trump we've been
speaking with the editor uh Dr Eli
Merritt from Vanderbilt University
really appreciate your time today thank
you so much
great to be with you David